- We were just talking about
how music impacts everyone,
hearing and deaf.
And in the film 'Amelia's'
character auditions
to get into Berkeley College of Music,
one of, if not the best
music school in the country.
Let's see this audition.
(screen whooshing)
(classical music)
♪ I've looked at love that way ♪
♪ But now it's just another show ♪
♪ You leave 'em laughing when you go ♪
♪ And if you care, don't let 'em know ♪
♪ Don't give yourself away ♪
♪ I've looked at love
from both sides now ♪
♪ From give and take ♪
♪ And still somehow ♪
♪ It's love's illusions I recall ♪
♪ I really don't know love ♪
♪ At all ♪
(audience applauds)
- My goodness.
(audience clapping)
That last 'At all',
Oh my gosh!
(audience clapping)
That was Joni Mitchell's
song, 'Both Sides Now'.
- Woo!
- I mean, it's such an
important song in general.
It's just such a cool song,
like her meaning.
- Oh my God.
- I'm behind it.
But then to translate it to
the meaning of the movie,
I literally couldn't
listen, you saw me going
(host imitating)
(laughing)
- I loved it.
- While we were playing the clip,
cause I was like, I will lose it.
(laughing)
It was that.
I mean, it had to be.
You're nailing an American accent.
You're singing,
you're signing,
you're... It's such an important message.
Important part of the film, like...
(audience clapping)
What was doing that song
like for you in that moment?
- I mean the lyrics speak for themselves.
- Good gosh.
- Yeah. I actually watched
a Joni Mitchell documentary
not that long ago.
And she said that song is the
work of her childhood's end
and Ruby is at the of childhood.
She...
(indistinct talking)
You know, she said the
moment in life when...
- Was so poignant.
- Figure out.
- Yeah!
- Well, you know who she is
outside of her childhood identity.
We also shot that scene
in the last week of shooting, I think.
And, I was getting so emotional
about the film being over.
I'd obviously trained for so long.
And so the movie had been
such a big part of my life and
I am so close with Marlee, Troy and Daniel
and Lonnie Owen.
I was just getting so
emotional about it being over.
And I remember I looked up
and I signed I love you.
And then I just got really emotional
and...
(host awing)
I forgot how the melody went at one point.
And it's actually the take
that Sean used in the movie
because I guess...
- Yeah.
- That's emotion that is not fake.
It's real.
There was so much love making it.
- Yeah, I'm gonna cry.
- And it was real.
It was so real
watching her go through
each different take
but she did it with ease and I...
Of course it was hard
but she made it look so.
Such at ease.
And there's so many factors that
it turned out to be the most
beautiful scene together.
And I have to say that
Joni Mitchell actually tweeted about
- What!
(host imitating)
- Yeah, she Instagramed and tweeted me.
(audience clapping)
- Oh my gosh
- I know. I fangled hard.
I was freaking out.
I...Its my friend said, "Oh,
Joni Mitchell airted you."
And I was like,
sorry,
(laughing)
like, it was surely just
a fan account account
or something, you know, like
(laughing)
and I checked and yeah,
like she...
- Wow!
- She said incredible performance
and she was congratulating
us all on the nominations.
And she just...
I mean... As I said,
I was nervous about the song.
So that was just like the cherry on top.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah.
I couldn't believe it.
- Though,
(indistinct talking)
to seeing that scene
feel different for you
than actually filming it because
your character comes in
and kind of boost her
confidence in a moment
where she's feeling shaky.
And I imagine you're acting,
you're in the moment,
you're doing it.
Imagine there was a
whole different feeling
while filming it,
but afterwards watching it,
did it hit you in a...
Like it hit everyone else?
- Absolutely.
I just watched it for
first and because of COVID,
I was not able to watch in a
big screen and with people,
I just saw a card they
send me in my computer.
So I...
It was like probably a
couple of months ago.
We were in a screening
doing all this promotion
when I watched it with people
all around in a theater
and I cried so bad.
I mean...
I was so touched by
especially by that scene.
It's beautiful.
I really got into it.
I didn't remember what I did.
I was just watching Amelia performing
and the music so beautiful
that yeah... It totally got me.
- I did sit next to
him and all I heard was
(snuffling)
(laughing)
- Oh my God!
I have never been more grateful
for watching a movie alone.
(laughing)
Its Like I do remember my kid,
my five year boy came into the living room
after I was finished watching.
And he was like, "What's wrong with you?"
(laughing)
And I was just like, "Oh! so beautiful."
I was like...
I was like, it was Ghastly.
It was a mess.
(laughing)
It's...
Literally, I'm gonna keep saying it
(laughing)
but it's such a great film
and...
(audience clapping)
give it up.
I have been dying to
interview these people.
Thank you so much for
honoring me with your time.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
Give it up one more time
for the cast of Coda
(host clapping)
as well as their interpreters.
Thank you guys so much for being here.
Thank you! Thank you!
You can see Coda streaming
now and apple TV plus.